whether we live near a coastline or not
seafood is an increasingly popular
option for Americans the u.s. is now the
second largest consumer of seafood
worldwide right after China the Centers
for Disease Control says about 20% of
adults are eating fish at least twice a
week but choosing your fish doesn't
always mean getting what you're after
meg Oliver has that story good morning
Meg tell us more good morning Michele
recent investigations and studies have
shown mislabeling sometimes due to error
but often the result of outright fraud
is rampant in the industry showing up at
both in the marketplace and on
restaurant menus
I spoke to local merchants who told us
exactly what to look for
there's no antibiotics and there's no
growth in answers there's none of that
every week
Lisa Rosenberg peppers her local seafood
markets with plenty of questions from
salmon and scallops to shrimp Lisa wants
to know when and where everything came
from just knowing that the seafood we're
getting is fresh and coming from a
country that has shipped it in a timely
manner and markets it and is honest with
their marketing practices those
practices have come under fire around
the globe with rampant fraud in all
stages of the seafood industry one study
of retailers found seafood like grouper
cod and snapper may be mislabeled up to
87 percent of the time swapped out for
less desirable in cheaper varieties for
example only seven of the 120 samples of
red snapper were actually red snapper
it's a very big problem and the issue is
that once it's prepared there's really
no way to to check it other than DNA
testing which a lot of companies are now
doing
vini Milbourne hails from a long line of
fishermen the fishmonger Greenpoint fish
and lobster company in Brooklyn New York
specializes in local domestic and
traceable species his storefront acts as
a fish market raw bar in restaurant
where do you buy your fish I have a
network of small boat fishermen and
wharves all over the country that are
shipping to me daily through the air or
by truck and we are processing every
single day to bring in high-quality
fresh seafood this is a beautiful
steelhead trout Vinnie not only knows
where his fish come from he can tell a
tale about each one this striped bass
came from Massachusetts from a fishing
vessel named Stanley by a guy I know
named Seth that personal connection is
hard to find it's estimated more than
90% of the seafood consumed in the u.s.
is imported in less than 1% is tested by
the government
is it better to buy organic seafood not
really in this country there's no legal
standard four-seat for organic for
seafood no legal standards no when they
did the organic standards for meat and
poultry and chicken they excluded
seafood so when you see organic on on
seafood it's not a legally enforceable
standard so they can put that on just
about anything
Larry Olmstead is the author of real
food fake food he spent years
researching the unregulated food
industry calling fish the most
frequently faked food Americans buy the
inexpensive fish that are being
substituted a lot of them are farmed in
Southeast Asia from places that have
been shown over and over again to use
bad practices banned drugs banned
pesticides the bottom line is a lot of
the fish that we eat we don't know where
it came from or how it was produced at
all
so how dangerous is this I think it's
pretty dangerous
there's tens of millions of people that
get sick from foodborne illness every
year that the CDC cannot explain if they
don't clean it up and we don't see more
regulations what could happen in the
future the destructions of the ocean and
it's the single biggest source of
protein in the world we have a
burgeoning global population since the
history of mankind having enough
to eat has been the number-one priority
of people so it's really important that
we take care of the oceans Larry says
the best course of action for consumers
is to buy whole fish he says don't be
intimidated you can have them cut it and
clean it for you so you then you know
exactly what you're bringing home to
your families are you stunning here it's
yes something there's no legal standard
for organic seafood no and if you're
gonna go and you want to buy organic
seafood make sure it comes from Canada
New Zealand or Australia they're the
only countries that have regulations and
at a time when regulations are being cut
left and right sounds like this is a
place where we really need you yeah yeah
Meg thank you so much